welcome to this video taxi from Cuba no
name okay knows that can I do something
else not the Queens gambit all the time
what about this they play this recently
hit the vessel for opening with Bishop
f4 funny enough not with Bishop g5 let's
see c6 I think they do this preparing a
form and then oops this this kind of
thing it's not that not that crazy why
does gaining quite some space in the
center and yeah it just leads to fresh
positions been played quite a lot by
some GM's even in especially in rapid
and blitz Jess not so much not so much
in classical time controls but players
like Jabbar Nakamura they if they have
played this chair well aged six on age
50 it's not much else really maybe you
can play no he then I Queen B 6 maybe
but hard to believe okay so this is a
little bit it's a little bit it's not so
well organized here I can maybe get an e
for quickly I can can go for night age
42 f forward I think if ice is good to
play I wonder if he can play five maybe
i'm not sure like efore takes takes d5 I
always can be very about very of those
things destroying my pawn structure okay
i will take this time to prevent before
i really want the night on f4 Alice's i
can do it for now yeah maybe now that
he's not ready to play you five this is
possible it's all of course an issue
what to do with my kingdom castling
short looks kinda area and castling long
after playing 8 a 3 s also lil bit dicey
maybe six
that's basically saying I have all the
time in the world probably to play c5 I
want light therefore so I'm playing
Bishop e3 that's also aimed against see
hive yeah let's do that I mean I think
he should consider to just yeah heck
this off it cost me some time but at
least mine I've got the bishop pair now
let's see here yeah maybe I should
cancel short I mean why not I wonder
about be three if I should do that just
trying to prevent this yeah maybe night
c4 is a real annoyance if it hits so
maybe take this time Bishop 2d6 to
prevent c-5m now my development is
definitely not grade
the good Bishop e3 he will play e5 yeah
I'd always cost sometime if you're
basically reinventing the game from move
one or still castling long let's do that
keeping pressure on d5 and so on maybe
you can take if I can take with the
night ii five is not good yeah I take
twice and then f4 f5 basically wins the
bishop yeah I don't know look narrow pH
cannot play okay I don't know I really
don't have the time to to figure it out
in detail and so trying to play play
quickly interesting
the interesting thing is I can maybe
maybe I can sacrifice taking on c6 no
probably not can I clean my king is
shaky definitely and there are tactics
95 Bishop t6 was my idea but maybe you
can play Knight c3 things like that oh
yes I am i king that's not good
so Bishop t6 is probably not on ok I
have to probably see that I get Luke a
one plate so that I'm not checkmated
immediately I'm not saying that I am NOT
checkmated now it's possible we should
be 493 mm-hmm oh no my king I think even
a simple move like now at ninety-seven
to be six is probably good for him yeah
that's it's probably just good for him
you can take and play Knight b6 or
something like that which which is
simply good what I couldn't really spend
any longer you are needed to play and
there are ideas like Bishop before
Knight c3 that are also really dangerous
check okay yeah this is definitely also
dangerous but is it is it losing I don't
know you for hangs maybe can I can I can
I do that keep keep the keep the party
for intending c5 he's doing this himself
t5 no I have no time to figure it out
check
just trying for some kind of counter
play check not sure what happens here
maybe I'm checkmated but maybe I'm not
this this could be chick made bishops
III
it's going to look in three
I only have nine second sim check check
check
now that's the problem now I have no
move yeah white yeah well this is this
was really really weird we had stuff
yeah my king was was in a problem all
the time you on the queenside check I
really think that I know around here
yeah it felt like I should have
something this is a real counter check
but maybe maybe not i mean how to say
yeah okay here white is totally winning
according to the computer i can just
take it why I didn't I thought I'm check
made it but maybe I'm not obviously I'm
not as the computer says I'm just
winning him check so I'm not made Yemm I
can shiny I can really just escape how
idiotic is that I can just go to the
tree now I just I was just hallucinating
yeah I thought there's a direct
checkmate threat so I thought I have to
to do something against it that's lame
you just take this and he resigns gem
and add some time that's embarrassing
but ok well the whole low position was
of course bad around here I think I
should be in quite good shape but it's a
very tricky position to play I'm not
used to this this type of thing I'm not
sure be three in here ok went here yeah
hit it gets really interesting he's got
before coming you know the computer
likes that actually at least them on
this first kind of quick inspection here
it wants to play 94 though yeah maybe
it's better just keep things closed 94
threatens Bishop t6 so it's not
bad guarantee I have my doubts really
this looks very shaky from my king
compounds to do this yeah I thought oh
yes at least that was my idea and the
comp says it's a draw I can just take
yeah okay yeah I don't know very
difficult but I wasn't sure about this
as well this either I keep saying as
well but i should say either i learned
that at one time but somehow didn't
didn't register in my brain okay well
this was to brio just taken the Queen oh
ok thanks for watching